hi I'm Michael Bolton and I'm doing a
wired audio complete autocomplete
interview it feels like a tongue twister
for some reason what is Michael Bolton's
most famous song the ode to Pippi
Longstocking no that's not it
how am I supposed to live without you
what is Michael Bolton's
real name it's below - Michael Bilotti
Russian can't imagine where I changed it
what song is Michael Bolton rapping
office space I have no idea you tell me
why does Michael Bolton's phone number
203 nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
what is Michael Bolton's zodiac sign no
it's a Pisces what is Michael Bolton's
vocal range forty seven octaves how many
awards does Michael Bolton have endless
how many Grammys does Michael Bolton - I
have two for Best Male Vocalist I was
nominated for out of six years can't win
them all
how much does Michael Bolton weigh about
four pounds three ounces too much okay
this is how can I Michael Bolton
how long is Michael Bolton's hair I cut
it in 96
where is Michael Bolton from Connecticut
New Haven Connecticut USA where did
Michael Bolton go to college oh I've
been to Yale University but only to
perform on campus I left school when my
mother co-signed a contract to make
records for CBS records I was 16 I went
to the University of Life
where's Michael Bolton today where is
Michael Bolton performing called my
website look it up because that's the
only way I know it's that sad way to
Michael Bolton grow up
I didn't does Michael Bolton play
clarinet
not that he knows of does Michael Bolton
still perform six months see everywhere
on earth there's Michael Bolton have a
brother yes I have an older brother Oren
does Michael Bolton sing butterfly
kisses no but I do get stopped in the
airports and people tell me how great my
performance of butterfly kisses was
just smile tonight thank you here's how
I remember butterfly kisses
run after damn butterfly kisses I don't
know is Michael Bolton going to continue
this single there's only one of me
it's Michael Bolton dead that's not a
nice question
no is Michael Bolton Canadian I can't
believe nom nom is Michael Bolton a
vegetarian yes almost 46 years so since
I was three months old is Michael Bolton
hit Kenny G's brother in a way we have
similar noses alright I'm warmed up can
we do the real thing though